every journey begins with a solitary
foundational level certification and for
aws that starting point is the aws
certified cloud practitioner
hello everyone i'm shanley and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on how to become an aws certified
cloud practitioner
the aws certified cloud practitioner
certification gives you a high level
overview of aws
it doesn't go into a great detail about
any one service instead
focuses on the overall structure of aws
and a basic understanding of what the
various servers accomplish
so in this video i will take you through
the path of becoming
a successful aws certified cloud
practitioner
starting with what is an aws cloud
practitioner
followed by the eligibility criteria for
the exam
then we will discuss the exam objectives
then we will look into the exam content
followed by how to prepare for the exam
then we will have a look at some of the
sample questions for your reference
and then we'll discuss
some tips you should remember while
taking the exam
so without any further delay let's get
started with the video
so what is an aws cloud practitioner
the aws certified cloud practitioner
certification is a foundational level
test designed for people who can
successfully show an overall
understanding of the aws cloud according
to amazon
the skills necessary for specific
employment types such as developers
administrators and solution architects
are not assessed by this certification
aws recommends that you have
at least 6 months of aws cloud
experience
now let's look into the eligibility
criteria for the exam to proceed further
anyone with a basic understanding of the
aws platform should take the exam
we recommend that you have the following
factors before taking this exam
first
six months of aws cloud experience
second understanding id services and how
they are used in the aws cloud platform
is a must
and third is basic understanding of aws
services and use cases invoicing and
pricing mechanisms
security concepts and how the cloud
affects your organization
moving on let's have an overview of the
exam
the exam consists of 65 questions and
has a 90 minute time restriction
to pass the exam you must get at least
700 out of 1000 points that is 70
the exam has multiple choice one right
response from four possibilities and
multiple response questions two correct
responses from five options
the cost of applying for the exam is
hundred dollars and the certification
needs to be renewed after every two
years
now that we know of the eligibility
criteria for the exam let's move ahead
and have a look at its objectives
it will enable you to articulate the
value proposition of aws cloud
next you will be able to define the aws
cloud and aws global infrastructure with
it
also it will help you understand and
explain the fundamental aws cloud
architectural ideas
it will enable you to describe the aws
platform's essential security and
compliance features as well as the
shared security model
you'll be able to define invoicing
account management and price models with
it
and it will also enable you to describe
the fundamental code properties of aws
cloud deployment and operation
now let's proceed further and have a
look at the content for the exam for
better and organized preparation for the
exam
the required knowledge is divided into
four domains for the exam these are
various objectives within each test
domain that broadly reflect the
knowledge and expertise required to pass
the exam
cloud concept
this domain makes up 28 percent of the
exam
security this domain makes up 24 of the
exam
technology makes 36 percent of the exam
and billing and pricing makes up 12
of the exam
the following three goals are included
in cloud concepts
they find the aws cloud and the value
proposition it provides recognize
characteristics of the aws cloud's
economics
and make a list of the various cloud
architecture design principles
you should be able to explain the
advantages of public cloud services and
define the services that are offered on
aws like
iaas eas and saas
you must comprehend the financial
benefits of cloud computing and the
distinction between
c a p e x and o p e x this relates to
item one
you should be familiar with cloud
architectural design principles such as
loose coupling scaling bootstrapping and
automation to mention a few
now comes security
you should be familiar with the aws
shared responsibility model which
specifies who is in charge of which
component of the technology stack from
the data center to servers firewall
rules and data encryption
aws offers tools and services for
deploying security evaluating your
security posture and creating alert and
compliance reports you must be
have a thorough
understanding of these services and
tools in order to describe their use and
benefits now comes technology
you must know what the basic aws
services are and how they are used
you usually don't need a thorough
understanding of a services specifics
but you do need to comprehend its goal
benefits and use cases ec2 ecs
lambda light sale ebs efs s3 rds
dynamodb
redshift elastic load balancing auto
scaling cloudfront root s3 cloudwatch
cloudtrail and sms are all core services
you should be familiar with the aws
cloud's worldwide infrastructure
regions availability zones and edge
locations are all part of this
then comes billing and pricing the
majority of aws services are available
on a pay-per-use basis
however there are also alternatives to
save money by signing one or three year
contract with a variety of payment
options
you must comprehend these models and the
services to which they apply
make sure you know what aws will charge
you and what will be free inbound data
transport for example is free whereas
outbound data transfer is usually
expensive
vpc cloud formation and iam are all free
services but the resources you generate
with them may not be
you must be aware of the potential for
cost to arise
now let's have a look at how to prepare
for the exam
step 1
start with aws training classes aws
cloud practitioner essentials
aws cloud practitioner technical
essentials
and cloud business essentials are a few
courses that will help you build your
knowledge in aws
step 2 go through exam guides for aws
certified cloud practitioner
certification because they give you an
idea of important concepts to focus on
for the exam as well as give you an
overview of all the exam objectives and
the pattern of questions
step 3 get familiar with subject areas
before the exam analyze the important
subjects for the exam and keep polishing
your knowledge in that area by constant
revisions
step 4
self sadhu to build your strength self
study is ample to clear this exam just
go through the aws training go through
the study material available online and
keep revising
step 5 examine sample questions and take
a free practice test practice sample
papers from various website present
online to see where you stand and how
much you know and how much time you take
to keep a track of your performance and
improve yourself
and six
schedule the exam and get certified
once you feel you are ready prepared and
confident enroll for the exam choose a
center near you for the aws child
practitioner exam website and just
register yourself
so let me give you a glimpse of some
sample questions based on each domain
first question
which feature of aws allows you to
deploy a new application for which the
requirements may change over time
option 1 elasticity option 2 fault
tolerance option 3 disposable resources
and option 4 high availability
the answer is option one you can deploy
your app without worrying about whether
it will require more or less resources
in the future
thanks to
elasticity infrastructure can scale up
and down on demand thanks to elasticity
question 2
which aws service is used to enable
multi-factor authentication
option 1 amazon stf
option 2 aws iam
option 3 amazon ec2
and option 4 aws kms
well the answer is option 2 iam is used
to manage multi-factor authentication
and to securely regulate individual and
group access to aws resources
question 3 a company would like to
maximize their potential volume and
array discounts across multiple accounts
and also apply service control policies
on member accounts
what can they use to gain these benefits
option 1 aws budgets
option 2 aws cost explorer
option 3 aws iam
option 4 aws organizations
well the answer is
option 4
aws organizations allow you to create
groups of aws accounts and then
administer policies across all of them
from a single location
consolidated billing is available in
both features set of aws organizations
allowing you to set up a single payment
method in the organization master
account while still receiving invoices
for individual activity in each member
account
question 4
what advantages do you get from using
the aws cloud
you have to choose any two
option 1 trade capital expense for
variable expense option 2 stop guessing
about cap capacity
option 3 increase capital expenditure
option 4 gain greater control of the
infrastructure layers and option 5
comply with all local security
compliance programs
well the answer is option one and two
you may pay on a variable opex basis for
the resources you use and grow on demand
using public cloud services like aws so
you never have to guess how much
resources you need to deploy
question five
under the aws shared responsibility
model what is the customer responsible
for
choose two
option one physical security of the data
center option two replacement and
disposable of this drivers
option three configuration of security
groups
option four
patch management of infrastructure and
option 5 encryption of customer data
the answer is option 3 and 5
customers are responsible for creating
security groups network acls updating
their operating systems and encrypting
their data
while aws is responsible for the
physical security of the dc the
replacement of obsolete disk drivers and
infrastructure patch management
question six
what are two ways an aws customer can
reduce their monthly spend
choose two
option one
turn off your resources that are not
being used
option two use more power efficient
instance
types
option three reserve capacity where
suitable option four be efficient with
the usage of security groups
and option 5 reduce the amount of data
in dress charges
the answer is option 1 and 3
turning of resources that aren't in use
can help you save money reserved
instances can also help you save money
on a monthly basis without committing to
a one or three year contract which is
ideal for predictable workloads
question 7
what are the advantages of availability
zones choose to
option one they allow regional disaster
recovery
option two
they provide fault isolation
option three they enable the caching of
data for faster delivery to end users
option 4 we are connected by low latency
network connection
and option 5 they enable you to connect
your on-premises networks to aws to form
a hybrid cloud
the answer is option two
and four
each aws region has numerous
availability zones which are unique
locations each az is designed to be
isolated from other failures a data
center is an az and
in some situations an ez is made up of
numerous data centers
with an area hazard provides low cost
low latency network connectivity to
other zones within that region this
allows you to synchronize
duplicate your data between data centers
allowing the failover to be automated
and visible to your users
question 8
which aws support plans provide support
via email chat and phone
choose any two option one basic option
to business option three developer
option for global and option five
enterprise
the answer is option two and five only
the business and enterprise programs
offer emails chat and phone assistance
now that we have discussed all the
important aspects required for aws cloud
practitioner exam
let me give you some tips
you should remember while taking the
exam
first start by answering questions you
are familiar with to prevent spending
time on tough ones
it will give you confidence as well as
save you from wasting your time on
trying tough questions
second keep track of your time and learn
how to manage it in order to complete
all the questions distribute your time
according to the time available to the
number of questions so that you can work
on each question precisely
third analyze the question first then
respond as there may be traps in the
questions focus on keywords and try to
read them two to three times for better
understanding sometimes it is said that
answer lies in the question itself
fourth because there may be numerous
answers to a question
read and choose your answers carefully
if you feel there is a chance that
multiple answers are correct for one
question
then do go for it and analyze it wisely
before coming to that conclusion
well this was all about it so tell me if
you found this video helpful for your
preparations
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important do
let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on how to
become an ews certified cloud
practitioner and learn something new
from it if you like this video then
please hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here